that is a snack pack
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we will be reviewing
teen lifestyle youtuber caroline manning
but first of all i want to talk about my
sponsor
squarespace so a little story time but i
remember
when i started abby's kitchen way back
in the day
getting the website going definitely
seemed like the biggest hurdle
i just did not even know where to start
but when i'm coaching
new bloggers today they feel so
encouraged that services
like squarespace make it so much more
intuitive
and easy so if you're not in the know
squarespace is an all-in-one platform
for any website
blog or online store there are so
many amazing features between blogging
and commenting social media
and e-commerce extensions for those who
sell products of course online
i have been so blown away by how easy
and simple they pull together
all of those hard parts of getting a
business or passion project off the
ground
so that you can really just focus in on
what you do best
so if you're interested in getting
started you can check out
squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
slash abbey sharp to save 10 off of your
first purchase
of a website or domain all right and
super quick before we dive in here
you can pause this screen or you can
look in the description to check out my
general disclaimer including a trigger
warning
as in this format we will be looking at
some nutrition
stats and of course don't forget to
subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a future video
okay folks before we even get into
things i want to just preface
this review by flagging that i don't
think i've ever reviewed anyone as
young as caroline on my channel as a
teen youtuber
my approach is going to be a little bit
different and a little bit more nuanced
because
i want to be extra careful and cautious
to protect the integrity
of what i see as a really solid
relationship with food
now if i already were seeing a lot of
evidence of diet culture my intervention
would probably be shaped
a little differently but because things
do look good on that front
and i will talk more about that later my
goal here is to target some more gentle
nutrition strategies
that are realistic for a young girl like
caroline
who maybe is not likely fully in control
of her own meals
in the real world these recommendations
would be communicated also to the family
and not just to her as the team but
let's take a look at her day
actually first i need to interject so
i shot this video over a month ago and
literally a few days before it launched
caroline uploaded a new wedding a day
and let's just say i am a little
disappointed at the direction
things have gone i had been feeling
pretty excited that you know maybe i had
some faith that this generation
may be able to reject the diet mentality
but now i'm a little worried so
in her recent video caroline eats
a protein shake a banana a cliff bar
raspberries a kind bar and some popcorn
and then for dinner she has some kind of
like snack pack of some salami cheese
and pretzels
that's it that is literally
it now i'm not going to review this in
detail because well
there's not that much to review here but
i am going to say
that it is obviously deficient in pretty
much every nutrient
including of course calories this is
only
maybe 1200 calories tops and i know that
i just said that i was witnessing
caroline's good relationship with food
and i do appreciate that there isn't any
explicit demonizing of foods in her
latest video
but this is just not enough food
for a growing active girl these are
snacks
this is just snacks i didn't really see
her eat
an actual full meal and ultimately it's
just not enough
so i'm throwing it back to her october
wedding day where we had
a lot more food to work with in the
hopes that
all of you watching and hopefully she as
well
can take something away from my
suggestions
all right back to the original video i
do try to eat like kind of healthy i
guess
but like eating foods that i like and i
think that's really important as well to
just find what you like
and not limit yourself especially if
you're like young and stuff
hell yes girl um but you should also be
able to eat what you like even if you're
not young not to sound like an offended
old lady but i do get what she's saying
uh obviously when you're young your
metabolism is faster
your energy needs are higher and you're
probably not worrying as much
about what foods put you at risk of like
heart disease or
cancer or stroke but we can still think
about balancing
those fun foods with foods that help us
feel our best
and that's where gentle nutrition really
comes in but i do have to say
i mean watching this girl's videos
totally reminded me of my youth and how
like eating
used to feel before i started thinking
about what society had deemed as
healthy i don't know it's like a nice
trip down memory lane for me pre-diet
culture
and i think that we can all channel this
teenage or childhood mentality around
food
whenever we find ourselves going down
that road into
scarcity mentality i like to wash my
hands every morning
before i eat breakfast just because i
feel like it helps me feel sanitary and
also it's an excuse to use my new
pumpkin bath and body works so
i mean that is definitely a good habit
to get into
i mean even pre-covered the cdc
definitely recommended washing your
hands before you handle
or eat food so yeah hand washing
definitely gets a big thumbs up from me
let's see what she's eating okay so i
start off by eating this whole grain
really healthy cereal from trader joe's
but it tastes so good
whenever i try new cereals that are
healthy and they taste gross
i never buy them again but this one is
so good once i'm done making my cereal i
pop some of these trader joe's naturally
flavored blueberry waffles
into my toaster oven and you guys these
are so good
these waffles are literally the best
things ever
typically i'll eat a banana as well for
breakfast but
we ran out of bananas so i cannot do
that okay so
caroline talks about how most healthy
cereal
tastes bad to her so i am glad that she
found an option that she really likes
so this one from trader joe's has about
three and a half grams of fiber and
protein per cup
and 12 grams of sugar so this certainly
isn't
a bad option but just for reference
basic yellow box cheerios which are 100
whole grain
but not marketed as multi-grain or
healthy or anything
like that actually has four grams of
fiber and
five grams of protein and just two grams
of sugar
i only make this comparison not to
demonize trader joe's o's
but i bring it up because words like
multigrain
often carry what we call a health halo
that makes food seem more nutritious
than they actually are
so i'm just kind of saying don't be
fooled by really good marketing
if you have certain health goals in mind
when you're choosing a cereal or
any food for this matter always look at
the nutrition label
not the name to compare things like
fiber protein
and sugar content and of course choose a
cereal that you
actually like not just one that sounds
really healthy
that's kind of the point that i'm trying
to make here now all that being said
because this meal is relatively low in
protein
and low in fiber and healthy fats and
also pretty high in sugar
i mean it's got about 40 grams of sugar
to be exact
we could focus on some little additions
to really
bump up the nutrition without
compromising on
enjoyment so we could add in some greek
yogurt and fruit to the cereal
and we can add some like nut butter or
smashed up berries to the waffles
now i actually watched a more recent
what i in a day from her but i chose not
to showcase that day since
she didn't really give any information
on her dinner meal but
i do want to take a look at how she
actually tweaked her morning meal
herself
so let's take a peek i have my arbonne
chocolate protein shake
and then this chobani vanilla greek
yogurt mixed berry
i've been trying to like minimize the
amount of sugar that i would have
because i would have the same two
waffles every morning
which is filled with sugar and then pour
like so much syrup on top so this is
like the perfect balance i think
i get all my nutrients in the morning
and then i can also get some fruit in
here
and i honestly might get like a banana
or an apple or something to eat as well
okay so now in this updated wedding day
she definitely has a lot more protein
going on she's got a protein shake
and also some vanilla greek yogurt with
fruit on the bottom
but since caroline seemed so
enthusiastic about her original cereal
and waffle breakfast
i wouldn't want to take that away and i
also would never want her to associate
carbs with being
bad or something that she has to avoid
so we actually could meet kind of
somewhere in the middle
now even if her original breakfast was
higher in sugar than what she wanted
i think there's definitely room to add
back some fiber rich carbs
like some fruit or some whole grains and
i also wouldn't count the
fruit in a container of yogurt as a
serving of fruit
i mean there's actually very little real
fruit in those and while super delicious
they actually have around 14 grams of
added sugar
which again i actually think is totally
fine in the context of this breakfast
but we still would want to see some more
fiber rich whole fruit in there as well
so like i said before we could do the
cereal from breakfast one
with the yogurt and then add in some
whole fruit on top
or she could do the waffles that she
likes with the protein shake on the side
as for the arbonne product the protein
shake
i don't know i'm gonna save that little
rant for an entire arbonne
expose video so if you want to see that
leave me a link
below but i will just say that any
protein powder will do
it does not need to be from an
overpriced over-hyped mlm
but anyways it is really nice to see
some modifications as caroline just kind
of figures out
what is working to serve her body best
all right let's go back to the original
review day
i will take my daily medicine for the
morning i've been taking these two pills
over the course of quarantine i feel
like i've noticed such a difference the
two things that i take
are biotin and b12 biotin helps support
healthy hair
skin and nails and b12 helps support the
nervous system function
and it helps convert food into cellular
energy i mean
yes that is true that is exactly what my
nutrition 101 textbook would describe
as the physiological roles of these two
nutrients
and you know while i would say that yes
b12
is a nutrient of concern for a lot of
north americans
not just those who are vegetarian or
vegan fyi
but biotin
not so much as i discussed in depth in
my sugar bear hair video here
a review of the literature on the use of
biotin for hair growth suggested that
unless you have an actual deficiency
which is most often
linked to some sort of genetic or
underlying health cause
supplementing with more biotin isn't
going to help your hair likely and
severe biotin deficiency in healthy
individuals
eating a generally balanced healthy diet
is
virtually non-existent so she could
probably save her allowance
and skip that supplement right there
let's take a look at snack
on the bottom i put these yogurt
pretzels
that are my favorite snacks ever in the
whole entire world
please go to trader joe's do yourself a
favor and buy these because they're so
delicious
then on the next tier i put some
chocolate coconut almonds
i'm a huge fan of almonds and coconut
and chocolate
so these never disappoint then on the
third tier i broke in half this organic
raspberry mini bar that i got from
my local grocery store called h-e-b and
these are super healthy
and really good for you because they
have quinoa and chia seeds and then
finally on the top tier i put a babybel
light
cheese oh my god i am lowkey obsessed
with this snack tower
i would totally buy this for my toddler
and then secretly steal it for myself if
i don't know we ever conquer covet and i
get to leave the house one day with a
snack tower
in tow
anyways we definitely have some fun
snacks here i see some carbs in the
pretzels and the cereal bar and the
chocolate
we got a little bit of fat in the
almonds and a little bit of protein in
the baby bell now again a quick note on
yogurt pretzels these are legit one of
my
favorite sweet and salty snacks of all
time
and the trader joe ones are so good but
again i want to flag the health halo
status
just because they have the word yogurt
in the title doesn't mean
they're actually made with real yogurt
in fact the first ingredient in this
product is cane sugar
not actual yogurt and a serving of six
twists
have 18 grams of added sugar again
totally fine in moderation and one of my
personal favorite snacks
but often these health halos give people
the drive to eat snacks like this
in excess while swearing off something
that they maybe like
more like chocolate coated pretzels and
they see that as the bad
option and that often is how scarcity
mentality
starts substituting a food that you love
for food that you
think that you should eat i'm not saying
that this is what's happening with
caroline
she may just totally love them like i do
but i am flagging this as like an fyi
for you folks who are watching at home
now i do notice that we're having a
snack but not an actual
meal here and skipping meals in favor of
just having snacks
is actually a pretty typical pattern for
a lot of teens
but not fueling your body with regular
satiating meals
can often cause sugar cravings later on
in the day
since we're looking for those quick hits
of energy all day long
so for caroline i would really suggest
building this into a bigger more
substantial meal
with a little bit more protein and
healthy fat on board
so if she wanted it to be handheld and
convenient like the snack tower we could
throw some roasted chickpeas or some dry
roasted nuts into the snack tower
and then maybe pair it with like a wrap
or sandwich with some nutritious veggies
and a really nutritious spread like
hummus in there
let's take a look at what's next my
post-workout snacks are
probably my favorite because that is
when i'm so hungry
and all i want to do is just eat some
fruit then i went ahead and picked out
an
apple that i liked opened up my fridge
and looked for the fruit that i was
craving for the day
and that happened to be raspberries and
strawberries which are my
favorites okay so normally fruit is a
great nutrient-dense snack choice if
you're feeling like something light
especially if we're going with like a
higher fiber fruit option
like an apple or berries but because
caroline specifically
just finished a workout and she didn't
really have
a full meal before working out i would
definitely want to
beef this up with a source of protein so
she could throw those berries into a
protein shake or serve them on top of
some greek yogurt or cottage cheese
or she could pair the apple with like a
couple of hard-boiled eggs
so again it's not about taking food away
it's really just about adding something
to help boost up the satiety factor and
the nutrition
let's move along to dinner and today we
are having spaghetti
and salad with strawberries and apples
butter lettuce
pecans apples strawberries and then
cheese i made this try usually
i drink my chai cold but i bought these
packets from heb
so this looks like an awesome balanced
dinner and
totally something that i would make at
home so we've got protein and fat in the
beef
pecans and cheese lots of fiber rich
carbs
from the pasta and fruit and then a nice
variety of colorful antioxidant rich
produce as well
it's a simple accessible classic family
meal that
i'm sure definitely hits the spot and
also a recipe that would be really great
cooking inspiration for a lot of her
teen
young viewers all right lovelies we have
made it through
dinner let's talk about the stats and a
trigger warning
i am going to be talking numbers so of
course feel free to like skip
this piece if it's triggering to you so
my best
estimation is that caroline is consuming
around 2
000 calories with about 54 of calories
from carbs
34 from fat and 14 from protein
so all of that is within the american
pediatrics association recommendations
for really growing active teens so
nothing
majorly concerning right there she is a
little bit low in some key nutrients
most notably iron and vitamin d for a
growing teen
and as she already alluded to herself
her diet does contain
more added sugar than what she herself
says that she would like
so most health authorities recommend no
more than 6 teaspoons
or 25 grams of added sugar per day
now in this day at least caroline was
getting around 5 times that amount
now if i'm being honest when i was a
teen i totally did the same so
i am hesitant to even bring it up
because i don't want
any teen watching to go cutting out
carbs
teens are growing like they're active
and they actually need a lot of carbs to
thrive so
i mentioned this not i repeat
not to suggest that caroline cut back on
carbs
i love bread but there's a difference
nutritionally between
the types of foods that contain a lot of
added or
free sugars and foods that contain whole
naturally occurring sugars so whole food
sources of carbs
have their sugars bound up with healthy
fats fiber
protein and micronutrients so this is
really where we want to focus getting
the majority of the carbs in our diet
these are the foods that are going to
give us better energy levels and overall
nutrition
and since caroline herself brought up
the fact that she was trying to reduce
her added sugar intake
i want to shed light on some simple
little tweaks to help her do just that
but before i do let's talk about what
i'm really liking here
so i think caroline is doing an awesome
job planning snacks
that satisfy her physical and emotional
needs
she's likely eating enough calories and
not omitting any food groups that may
leave her
more susceptible to nutrient
deficiencies
after watching some of her other wedding
days and vlogs
i would say that her meals and snack
ideas are easy and accessible for
other teens and honestly for a busy teen
she's got a good balance of convenience
foods
and homemade meals i love that she was
involved in preparing the dinner meal
with her family since
getting into the kitchen and honing
those culinary skills
is actually one of the best strategies
to inspire healthy eating
and a balanced relationship with food in
young adults so i say a big yay for home
cooking
now let's talk about some tiny little
tweaks that i would suggest help
caroline achieve her goal
of reducing the added sugar in her day
now i want to reiterate that i am
not advocating for any kind of low carb
diet here
nor do i think that caroline should
restrict or cut out or avoid
any of the foods that she loves in fact
i don't even think that she should
change the proportion of her diet that
is coming from carbs
it just comes down to choosing foods
that will help her feel her best
so if she wants to optimize her energy
levels we could try to incorporate a few
more fiber rich
whole food carbs into her day so my main
suggestion
would be to aim to get an actual
sit-down lunch meal
instead of just another snack on the go
that change alone
would likely help her meet those
micronutrient needs and also balance out
the added sugar in her day
especially if we can include a source of
iron rich protein like beans
legumes eggs tofu meat nuts or seeds
which would also help her meet those
really high iron needs for teens
i also would say you know just enjoy the
carps
but let's try not to let them be naked
so if you remember from my video on pcos
naked carbs
are just kind of what they sound like
they're a source of carbs
at a meal or a snack with nothing else
to beef it up
but by pairing that carb with protein or
fat
or at least choosing a higher fiber
option
we'll see more stable energy levels and
better staying power
so let's add nutritious foods to the
carbs and not think that we need to just
cut them out i also want to talk about
caroline's relationship with food
now i have to just say it is really
refreshing to see
a normal teenage girl eat like a normal
teenage girl
sure we could probably all agree that
yogurt pretzels are not as nutritious as
yogurt
and blueberry waffles are not as
nutritious as blueberries
but i'm just happy to see a young girl
with a profile as
big as hers on the internet not
promoting
some kind of bogus cleanse so this kind
of content
is really important for young girls and
boys to watch
in fact this is exactly how i used to
eat before diet culture got a hold of me
and i wish more young people could just
like
relish in this outlook on food a little
bit longer
or like i don't know for life but
honestly this is such a delicate age so
i do want to encourage caroline to focus
on those little changes
to help balance out enjoyment with what
feels good
in her body and gives her the energy
that she needs
to do the things that she loves don't
let diet culture tell you that you
shouldn't eat sugar at breakfast
but if you find the energy is waning by
second period at school
let's try to find some strategies to
help bulk that up
this is really what gentle nutrition is
all about
honoring your body and your mind and
doing so
in the most sustainable kind way
possible
i'm just gonna pop back in here again to
reiterate that i am
saddened by the latest wedding in a day
video
i am really hoping that this was an off
day and that caroline
isn't slowly like whittling away at her
intake
because you know between working out and
cheer practice that day
the girl needs her calories now it is
not
uncommon for teenagers to graze their
way
through the day but i really would like
to see her prioritize some balanced
meals
back into the mix so this is my gentle
nudge to caroline whom
i really do hope can find a happy medium
between
listening to her body about maybe
consuming excess added sugar
and fueling her body with enough
calories and energy to grow
adolescence is not the time to be under
nourishing
so folks that is all that i have for you
guys today thank you again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
if you liked it give me the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on some other
youtubers to review
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you